[Musique]
m
deep civilisation les clio le mot bio
manger pas à mon âge je n'ai pas le
droit de parler de tout ça et j'ai pas
encore autorisé puisqu'il sait des
étapes mais c'est les dialyses djallit
qui signifie le sens dans notre société
dans le manding le sang nous avons
attribué sur mon bios pour signifier un
peu on est bio
on ne devient pas brio
le rôle du griot date depuis le xiiie
siècle par l'empilement des vampires
mandingue qui s'étendait du mali au
sénégal gambie guinée-bissau guinée
conakry etc
à l'époque il n'y avait pas de
l'écriture pour dater les événements y
avait quand même l'équité dans le mal et
ne pas pour dater les événements donc
les griots ont été choisies ou tenir
compte de tout ce qui se passe dans l'
empire en émaux si l'afrique mondial
était une personne vivante
vous savez le sens le rôle du sang dans
un corps humain est quand même très
important et bien les glio c'est là le
sens né dans une famille de griots est
une grande école l'école de vie où il
n'ya pas des bits ou de cahiers pour
écrire il faut mémoriser et c'est une
transmission de père en fils de père en
fils de parentis jusqu'à nos jours
dans l' empire mandingue le roi a
toujours hissé guyot à côté de lui comme
conseiller l'aiguillon participent eux
aussi à des guerres pour encourager les
gagner le soir et cetera et cetera
conseiller ce rôle est toujours là ya
jamais eu de mariage de baptême
sans le griot ni de décès sans le brio
c'est le trait d'union de la société le
meneur des pelles ambassadeur de la paix
lâche yves
c'est sur ça que nous sommes basés quand
on paie aujourd'hui parler de l'histoire
moderne être fiers l'histoire moderne
c'est grâce à ce peuple le griot de père
en fils de père en fils et qui m'a valu
aujourd'hui être 60/70 soixante
quinzième génération
des griots de père en fils et mes
enfants sidiki c'est la 72e générations
de père en fils
ça on ne rencontre pas ça tous les jours
et c'est pas dans tous les pays y
compris vost c'est très important c'est
une valeur car un peuple qu'il n'a pas
d'histoire
c'est un peuple qui n'a vraiment pas
dedans c'est ce qu'on a l'habitude de
dire et je dirai tout simplement que ce
rôle du griot est parti de rien mais
aujourd'hui il est où il est où le
président de la république aujourd'hui
du mali à ses griots chaque famille a
ses gli occhi connaît éventuellement
l'histoire de cette famille là comme je
disais qu'ils être griot ce dîner comme
les codes de la vie on doit apprendre la
certain temps on doit pas te dis vous
devez pas moins tout à l'heure j'ai
demandé la permission recherche de
griots de pouvoir prendre la parole
c'est in ear agissent comme ça que ça se
fasse
c'est une éducation vous pouvez voir le
griot il est oublié
[Musique]
vous avez envie de se marier alors il va
faire les démarches de ce mariage en
tant que lio othon bio et le jour du
mariage
les démarches celui qui est là encore
pour assurer l'animation
si au bout d'un certain temps il ya un
enfant qui arrive ou des enfants qui
arrivent et les griots et se transforme
tout de suite encore aux griots de ces
enfants là j'étais a dit qu'il est
toujours au point zéro
il a fait les démarches pour avoir une
fin pour construire une famille et même
les enfants de cette famille da il est
leur grille est aussi il est toujours en
bas il fait il donne des conseils à
travers tout en gardant l'histoire c'est
une histoire orale c'est très complexe
et ça demande beaucoup de travail
les guyot on parle pas d'esclavagé n'a
pas d'esclaves
l'empereur du monde et n'a jamais fait
d'après les clio le chef
l'empereur du mali n'a jamais fait un
duo un esclave jamais c'est important
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
jusqu'aujourd'hui sur rôle du griot
continue ses passages appellez ça y est
c'est parti de rien mais c'est tout
aujourd'hui c'est très important
ce rôle qui continue on peut vraiment
pas se passer du rôle de glio dans notre
société moderne
aujourd'hui certes nous avons eu la
chance de pouvoir transporter puisque le
monde a vraiment besoin de la
communication si dans l'empiré dans
depuis le xiiie siècle il y avait ce
livre a faisait la guerre avec une truie
ou s'ils avaient la paix les griots y
composer une chanson parce que la
musique elle est quand même très
important c'est un moyen très efficace
pour faire la communication et nous
avons les instruments comme la kora
le balafon le djembé le n'goni lingoni
etc comme instrument les gens ils y
jouent les instruments etc des paroliers
aussi raconte l'histoire les femmes
chantent et ans c'est ça le rôle des
clients aujourd'hui nous partons nous
prenons cette musique
cette tradition ce rôle du griot en
dehors de ce continent ou de l' empire
mandingue en rencontrant d'autres
cultures comme espagnols comme
américaine etc et cela a valu
aujourd'hui que le mali détient le
record du grammy awards dans l'histoire
de la culture et l'afrique
et dieu merci grâce au brio une
dissonance et là on a toujours dit que
le mali est un pays financièrement
parmi les pays les plus pauvres du monde
mais culturellement numéro un parmi les
pays les plus riches en culture je pense
que si commun l'argent c'est le nerf de
la guerre c'est important si on a tous
et qu'on n'a pas de culture
c'était points c'est quand même
important si on a tué sont pas on sait
pas qui on est la réalité c'est
difficile nous avons ici dans ce pays
on est parti ensemble la culture et tout
ce qu'ils voulaient et nous ne sommes
fiers de le faire aujourd'hui
[Musique]
cette musique des clio jouer aujourd'hui
si vous voulez bien dans des styles
comme le jazz comme le blues comme le
rock n roll comme du reggae comment la
musique flamenco et caetera et caetera
et c'est cette musique de guyot a
rencontré toute cette musique là et
tenez vous bien quand nous rencontrons
ces cultures
ce n'est pas leur culture ou leur
musique nos jumeaux non c'est notre
musique qui est la musique d'aiguilhe ok
nous jouons nous faisons des
compositions etc
oui mais c'est pas par exemple quand
j'ai joué j'ai rencontré bioko
qui a bien voulu venir à bamako ici à
les hisser son album un titre de son
album up et c'est ma musique que j'ai
joué la musique des griots elle voulait
ce contact dans sa musique parce qu'elle
avait déjà elle avait écouté la vache
tel merdier dans un tie-break aux
agneaux et qu'elle écoutait au fur à
mesure et c est là voulaient bien
ajouter cette musique la source en
musique c'est pour montrer l'importance
encore deedee bridgewater est venu ici
et c'est james iha nous l'avons aidé à
faire son album et qu'il a réussi encore
une fois de plus c'est un mystère autour
de tout ça mais c'est une valeur je sais
si si si cette valeur les immenses un
tri savent pas ce qu'est elle a été
conçue par des gens imaginaient depuis
le xiiie siècle et jusqu'aujourd'hui
nous voyons ces ossements la korac et
sidiki qui est la toute dernière modèle
de cora dans l'histoire du monde
aujourd'hui elle a 21 micro sur sa 21
micro pourquoi parce que la cour à elle
à 21 cordes
originellement c'était 22 corps mais la
toute première personne qui est notre
ancêtre dilemma doublé après sa mort on
a diminué la cour à dean corll ce qui a
fait 21 corps qui fait 3 x 7
et aujourd'hui on a les micros et avant
par avaya vais pas éventuellement des
micros du sud voilà la technologie
avance aussi et c'est au ciment aussi
continue à partir donc nous avons c'est
une comédie qu'il détient une cour à
midi jouez toujours pas avec les quatre
doigts aujourd'hui je tiens à remercier
la culture quand on pas de la culture du
manden de ces pays
1 co je n'oublierai pas que la kora que
je veux prendre comme exemple est le
cadeau offerte par la présidence de la
république du mali à tous les amis du
mali
[Applaudissements]
même si le chef de l'état doit se
déplacer pour aller à l'extérieur et le
corps après généralement fait partie du
lot et qui a offert comme cadeau
je pourrais vous citer quelques noms
aujourd'hui à plus d'une cinquantaine de
cours à 2 toumani diabaté il a voté la
musique qui sont entre autres dans des
salons de george bush george bush fils
juan carlos fait fidel castro armés de
leurs amis ado alassane dramane ouattara
zing d'anciens présidents chinois et
c'est la princesse de la belgique
le prince de monaco
sa majesté le roi mohamed 6 donc et
cetera et cetera et cetera la kora et
les présente et bientôt aussi j'étais
quand il ya deux mois il ya des demandé
mardi au président paul kagame et
bientôt comme notre chef de l'état est
le champion de la culture dans les eaux
africaines et ne courra aussi qui sert
et aux fêtes a mis au musée de deux
lignes africaines faut dire que c'est un
symbole parce que l'afld l'afrique m'en
donne le mandat a beaucoup d'instruments
traditionnels à cordes mais c est ce
moment traditionnel à cordes
on peut les rencontrer dans d'autres
pays aussi par exemple une grue n'y
change de nom au maghreb
on appelle route au maghreb en turquie
là le moyen orient en est un en asie et
à l'inconnu qui change de nom
la chorale reste le seul instrument
même si voulant rencontrer en australie
à s'y tenir ou 1
à melbourne vous demandez tout
simplement la personne il vous dira
certainement qu'il acura vient du mandé
cette cour à qu'il détient bien du mans
des dons si tout simplement vous dire
que c'est important et c'est j'ai appelé
la cour à la carte d'identité de la
culture mandingue
c'est très important aujourd'hui la
chorale est enseigné au conservatoire
j'ai eu à faire un tableau spéciale
d'instruction de base pour qui veut
apprendre à jouer à la kora et même par
correspondance c'est possible et c'est
ce qui a fait que les sauvages
universités à vendre ni quand docteur
honoris causa pour tout le travail qui y
est nous a donnés par rapport à la
chorale je n'oublierai pas ces braves
gens qui sont nos parents qui ont
commencé ce sont les griots dès 1960
jusqu'en 1965 au mali son client
l'ensemble instrumental national du mali
me paie mes parents mon père et ma mère
les rames et d'autres 10 65 65
ils ont payé l'ancien international du
mali ont travaillé pour le mali pour ce
peuple malien sans salaire pendant cinq
ans ça c'est les gliomes sens à l'heure
dès 1964 et 1965
nous avons tous ses privilèges
on nous a jamais oublié dieu merci dans
ce pays
tous les gouvernements qui sont passés
tous les présidents qui sont passées
nous ont tous
respecter et tout en sachant que ces
hommes là sont là ils sont là pour ces
pays il vient de ce pays
on les doit du respect et c'est ça qui
continue ce qui est quand même très
important
et quand il ya eu le coup d'état du 22
mars
j'avais eu à faire rapprocher les griots
avec mes aînés djelimady tounkara
bassékou kouyaté perd son âme kassé mady
diabaté
on s'est reconstitué à faire un groupe
avec des cubains qui s'appelait afro
cubisme
nous avons fait deux mois de tournée
avant le départ sans en faire du peuple
de ce pays sans un centime
on est parti avec la musique de ces pays
là pour parler parce que c'était le
moment où on a dit ok on va plus
financier on va appeler envoyer un
centime au mali parce qu'il ya ici a dit
ça mais bon je suis allé on a demandé
aux quais nous allons faire ça on nous a
dit ok si c'est bien que vous dites aux
partenaires de revenir roumanie et nous
avons fait dire moi de tourner le griot
du mal et pour parler du mali pour
palais de la culture du mali pour qu'on
puisse au moins parler autrement du mali
qu'est ce que les journalistes est ce
qu'elle est mauvaise plus qu'à raconte
on a réussi à faire ça
[Applaudissements]